it feels like a really big problem is
just that Facebook has a newsfeed at all
like it's not just posts that people are
sharing but it's also that they have
this sort of section of their page that
says newsfeed and they're not a news
organization and they don't have
journalists and it really is just sort
of an example of how Facebook is trying
to become the Internet yeah and the
source of all information and for a lot
of people that is the only source of
information for their news so you know I
I'm interested in like how do we go
forward especially when you're talking
to these companies that have a vested
interest in being sort of the entire
Internet and there's just a few
companies and then we have actual
journalists that are losing their jobs
across the country and we don't have an
actual journalism taking place so this
is a great question and let me tell you
what I think the problem is with
Facebook okay and one that they
recognized which is that and it goes
back to this small D democratization of
information the thing what you could and
you put your sort of nail on the head
there or hit the nail on the head which
is that the news feed really isn't about
news right and so what Facebook does is
it organizes all communication in the
same way so that whether it is a you
know a video of your son's graduation or
a Kim Kardashian promotion or a article
from Breitbart or an op-ed for the New
York Times or just a communication from
your friends it's basically organized in
all of the same ways right so we don't
have any of the cues the information
cues that we have in the offline world
replicated in the online world so that
if you go up to a supermarket checkout
counter right and you see a publication
as you approach the register that says
you know for example Hillary Clinton
part of satanic cult in Washington in a
pizza joint right you are probably going
to discount that you probably discounted
no matter what but you certainly aren't
discount as you go toward the cash
register because you know what the
National Enquirer the Weekly World News
and like are right but when it's
organized in front of you in your
Facebook newsfeed alongside every other
kind of information that you have right
it doesn't have some of
same triggers and signals that you would
have in the offline world and so that's
one of the so what they need to do is
try to figure out ways to develop those
information to use now one way that
they've tried to do this and then it
directly answers your question is that
they're doing an experiment right now
that they've done in Sri Lanka and for
other countries where they tried to take
the news out of the news feed I don't
know if you've heard about this right so
they said all right let's take the
actual journalism take it from the news
feed and put it in a separate news the
journalists in that country the media
organizations lost 40% of their traffic
right and it's like the best of all
intentions I think right but but because
the media environment in these countries
has adapted to Facebook and Google being
the main pipes to which they're going to
end up being you know getting the news
right and so you know again they're
damned if they do you damned if they
don't and the question is how can we
maybe sort of drive in the right
direction
[Music]
you